as the Bolivian election dispute
continues both the opposition and
government supporters took to the
streets the latter to show their support
for leftist President Evo Morales in San
Francisco Plaza for them
is the only one who took the people into
account I identify with this person
who's changed the destiny of the country
the governments before just looted the
natural resources and this person's
distributed the wealth and stipends for
our older children and pregnant women
they say Morales who was the
front-runner in campaign polls won the
election fair and square I say to the
opposition whoever loses in the voting
booth has to respect the democratic
process democracy is not coming out with
sticks and burning public buildings or
not recognizing results democracy is
respecting what the people have decided
there are significant doubts about the
election the supposed rapid count on
Sunday show president Morales and
Challenger Carlos Meza heading into a
second round run-off with 83 percent of
the votes counted then that count froze
for 24 hours when it resumed president
Morales was suddenly on the brink of
winning outright in the first round the
vice president of the Electoral Tribunal
said the delay discredited the electoral
process and resigned the Organization of
American States called for a runoff
Carlos Meza says peaceful protests will
be needed to force that if we don't
mobilize if we don't show our democratic
power in the street this government will
do what it wants with the election
results opposition supporters scarcely
needed telling Wednesday was the third
day they marched we are fighting to
defend our vote because fo Morales is
not respecting the will of the people he
is not respecting the laws he is not
respecting anything his time in
government is over and it isn't just in
La Paz but across the country there are
many people here that feel that
especially in recent years democratic
standards have been slipping
especially the country's industrial
center santa cruz saw street battles
[Music]
president morales has called it an
attempted coup citing the burning of
government buildings the opposition say
instead it's a cry for transparency and
change John Holman al Jazeera La Paz